又上课了啊。
先回顾一下昨天。
昨天讲的东西啊比较理论，比较概念。
所以我希望你们应该是轻微的记了一下笔记是比较好的是吧？课堂笔记那么上学的时候就得记点笔记呀。
回顾一下呗，昨天啊昨天讲的是故事的三大要素。
人物。
事件。
主题。
然后这三大要素呢。
我们说我们给他细分了8个小要素。
其中人物。
分四分三个小要素。
身份。
冀中的身份。
对吧然后欲望。
他想干啥？
动作。
他为了欲望。
采取的行动。
事件也分三部分。
问题。
这个事件的核心问题是什么？能否解决？
然后阻碍或者叫阻力。
啊，记住也叫沟壑，大部分教程里面是写勾壑俩个字难写。然后结果。
就说他能不能办成这个事儿啊？
遇到了哪些主力呀，你最后得给人。
一个结果对吧？你必须得这个事件得有结果呀，然后主题分正价值。
和附驾值。
我昨天反复强调啊，我昨天反复强调主题必须是正能量。
对吧而且是那种显而易见的正能量。
那为什么主题又分正价值负价值呢？
是因为正负价值在这个在你整个过程当中是有一个角力的过程的，所以负价值是会出现的。
但是最后是正价值，战胜了负价值。
体现了正能量。
那么。
故事的三要素细分成这8个小要素。
而且我昨天给大家说了一遍，我说你看。
一个什么样的人产生了一个什么样的。
想法欲望通过干什么事儿，想实现这个想法。
能不能实现呢？
大问题。
够呛难阻力很多，各种各样的阻力。而且我昨天说了，阻力一定程度上是决定故事精彩程度的关键就是阻力越大。
故事越精彩。
九九八西斤呢啊翻山越岭啊，就是阻力，然后最后得到一个结果。
这个结果呢体现了正价值，战胜了附加值，弘扬了正能量。
就是什么。
一个玩意儿。
昨天说的就是这个概念，然这个东西不是我发明的。
也不是我呃教给大家的。
这是书上。
这是原理理论。好吧，所以昨天咱们把这个交给了大家。
然后很多人就觉得那故事就这么简单吗？
那可不就是这么简单吗？
原理上就是这么简单。
我们说随便小蝌蚪找妈妈。
小蝌蚪想找妈妈，动作是游啊游，到处找，问题是能不能找到啊？
阻力是一次又一次的找错，抱上这个大锤叫妈妈，结果说我不是你妈，具体都找了谁，我不记了，我只记得抱过王八，找到王八说哎呀，你是我妈，然后呢，最后结果是找着了，确实找着了，而且他自己也长大了。
体现的主题是什么？就母子情深嘛，母子怜心，母子情深。
就是那么简单故事。但我上一节课啊，我特意没布置作业，我没有让你们顺着这个写一下，我就是怕打击你们的信心。你们好不容易培养起来说，哎呀，这故事太简单了，这不写一下吗。
一写就会发现，其实跟之前还是一样，还是不会对吧？为什么呢？因为这八要素就是原理，就是原理。你套上之后，这故事不一定就是只能保证你故事完整。
那么今天。
我们来讲什么呢？今天我们就讲八要素。
的实战应用。
实战应用啊，咱的咱的这课不是叫实战课嘛？咱得唠点，咱得聊点我的了，好吧，这个八个要素。
大家都明白了。
举个例子。
好不好？我刚才上课之前想了一下，我说我们举个什么例子呢？我们举个最耳熟能详最最简单的例子，今天不引用经典了，我们自己造一个故事，好吧，我们说来我们写某个人物的故事，这个人物的身份是什么？
你们说写个警警警匪故事好不好？警察抓坏人。我跟你说，警察抓坏人是目前剧类、电视剧类世界第一大题材。
世界第一大题材。
他就像古代的。
古代什么题材最吃香啊，什么妖怪来了，灾难片，然后或者是呃谁谁谁翻山越岭，上哪去找到了一个宝藏。那个那个阿里巴巴什么的，就是寻宝片和灾难片是古代人的第一大题材，他们爱听这。
现代人的第一大题材就是警匪片，警察抓坏人，警察抓小偷。
对吧这种是第一题材。所以我们啊那至于咱们有些同学马上产生疑问了啊，说中国为什么？
嗯咱们国内为什么警察抓？
小小偷的题材那么少呢。
自己去琢磨吧，自己去体会吧。反正你看陈思成是挺想拍警察抓坏人的片儿的。
他想要用中国演员演说汉语，拍我们中国的探案片，但是他跑哪儿去拍的跑。
跑泰国唐人街去拍去，对吧？就是就是那儿的事情呃，咱这就不说了啊，咱假设。
咱可以写这么一个精彩的故事，警察。
你告诉我来。
警察的欲望是什么？警察一般的欲望是什么？
警察维护正义啊。
他的盛个阳善呀，对吧？他欲望是。
正义。
警察呢一身正气正义。
来，为了实现正义。
他得有个动作吧。
他采取什么样的动作？
就是抓嘛，抓小偷嘛？警察抓小偷嘛，他他就去抓坏人，对吧？就抓捕，抓坏人。
然后问题就是能抓人吗？
能不能抓着，那肯定是肯定是显然是出现了一个特别难抓的。你看探片一般都是上来破几个小案子，既显示一下这个警察聪明机智、善良勇敢，还显示一下他这个这个呃有点什么过人的技能，反正就是把警察这个形象一树立，然后咔嚓来一个。
非常。
要紧的案子，神探夏洛克不就是这样吗？上来先破几个鸡毛蒜皮的小案子，显得他哎呦这个聪明华生都看呆了，对吧？那个卷弗演的那一版，然后马上就出来那个那个那个那个连环自杀案，夏洛克那个第一集，然后不就是成为了最大的问题嘛？最大的问题就是能抓着吗？
能不能能不能对吧？能不能行不行的问题，就是最大的问题。能不能阻力那就不用说了，那就是坏人太坏。
对吧。
我上集说过什么阻力得得得那个呀，得是全套的呀，得是各种各样的阻力啊，什么坏人太坏呀，队友不给力呀，对吧？老天又在这个时候又刻意捉弄呀，然后或者是自己又什么生产离婚关系，这个要破案，那么家里又不省心啊，那一般的警察不。
还有这种事儿嘛，就家里也不省心，反正就是主力，各种阻力，各种各种对吧？我给他说各种。
各种阻力。
结果是什么？
结果那肯定就。
抓着了抓着了，对吧？抓着了。
主题体现了什么？
邪不压正啊，正压了邪就是正义。
战胜了。
邪恶嘛？
因为正价值是正义，负价值是邪恶。
正义。
打扰了邪哥好，收工。
收功了。
多完整的故事，你们看啊，咱们来看啊，多完整的一个故事。
警察追求正义。
然后去抓捕。
抓捕坏人能不能抓着呢？
坏人太坏了，实在是狡猾，但是最后还是抓着。
体现了什么正义战胜邪恶。好。
把个部分都卡上了，大家有什么不满意的吗？
没有人由衷的想说一句，这他妈叫什么故事？
这个故事有什么好看的？我想请问。
这个故事有什么好看的？我想请问同学们。
这故事有什么好看的？
一个警察追求正义，想抓坏人，坏人可不太好抓啊，费了点劲抓掉了结束。
让你看2小时这个片儿。
票是送的光买爆米花，你都不看。
对吧。
所以我昨天跟大家说的是八要素有了，只能告诉你，保证故事的连贯性和完整性。
故事精彩。
还远远不够。
故事精彩些实哦，如果只背一下八要素，然后咱们这事儿就办成了，那真咱这课也不值钱了，是不是？
咱们来实战好不好？我来告诉大家，我在实战过程中这8个要素。
我是怎么做的？
来。
八要素啊。
我们这一行给他保留，就是我们的曾经。
我们给他保留。
第一个。
身份。
我们说身份。
其实就是人物的。
首先描述的一个东西。
检验一个人物的身份成功不成功？
怎么检验？
我有个很简单的办法。
就是讲给你身边一个朋友说，哎，我给你讲一个关于什么什么样人的故事。
他想听。
就成了。
他不想听，你就得再重新琢磨琢。
你跟你身边的朋友说，哎，我给你讲一个警察的故事。
他不会抬头的。
然后你先看了下咱们这个故事。
我给你讲一个追求正义的勇敢的警察的故事。
9乘5的几率他还是不会抬头。
对不对？
那这个事情怎么解决呢？
我有一个口诀。
叫给你的人物加上一个。
附加值的定语。
简单里去。
给你的人物。
加上一个含有。
副价值。
的定语。
那你原本这个这个故事。
附加值是什么？
邪恶。
那我们先最简单粗暴的运用，我们别也别含有附加值了，我们直接就。
升班附加值哎，你朋友跟你朋友说，哎，我给你讲一个邪恶的警察的故事。
这时候他有一半左右的几率会抬头说怎么个邪恶法？
哎。
不就开始有点效果了吗？
但是有些同学问了，那邪恶的警察追求正义。
跟后面不就矛盾了吗？我跟你讲，邪恶的警察也可以追求正义。
对不对？
他可以追求自我的正义。
或者他可以追求一个片面的争议。
或者是他追求一个误打误撞的正义，明白吗？就说不耽误他追求正义的。
而且邪恶不并不一定是它的全部嘛，我们说含有附加值的定语啊。
明白这个意思吧？
这是第一点。
人物。
我们可以这么改。
其实就是什么搞一个反向思维。我们举几个例子啊。
我们说假设主角的身份是一个教师。
我们说哎哎，我给你讲一个教师的故事。
讲一个老师的故事。
你的朋友不会抬头的吧。
然后你就想想，哎呀，这个附加值教师的正价值是什么？
呃呃呃呃这个这个聪明。
呃，博学。
有爱心。
慈祥。
然后呢呃这个这个这个像天使一样，对吧？然后这个。
温柔对吧？反正就是这些价值是传统来说教师的正价值。
那你就找反的嘛。
你告诉他哎，我给你讲一个。
对数学一窍不通的数学老师。
我给你讲一个连加减乘除都搞不定的数学老师。
你朋友马上抬头，那他怎么教啊？
对不对？他不就有兴趣了吗？
或者我给你我给你讲一个那个那个最讨厌小孩，看到小孩就想打着老师，对吧？鬼位teach欧尼子反正龙师。
你不就抬头了吗？
明白这个意思吧？加一个附加值。
加一个负加值呃，不是加一个。
那个你主题里面附加值含有主题里面附加值的定语。
给你的。
人物身份。
好吧，这是第一点。
开始有点。
有有点内味了是吧？开始体会到一点故事开始变得好一点点了吧。最起码你朋友抬头了，他问你，那后来呢对吧？你跟他讲讲讲，我给你讲一个呃这个这个邪恶的警察的故事，他会讲。那后来呢他会先听了。
然后欲望。
欲望的口诀是什么？
身份的口诀，我们说加一个含有附加值的定语，讲给你朋友听。
检测。
欲望。
你这个欲望是正义吗？
我觉得这个欲望差点意思。
怎么检测你的欲望够不够意思呢？
把你的欲望。
讲给一只猴子听。
讲给一只猴子听，猴子如果抬头了。
那你这个欲望就成了。
看到一只猴子过去蹲他旁边。
投子不是喜欢互相。
捉狮子嘛？你帮人捉一个对吧？捉捉猴子哎。
把你的欲望说给他。
咱们俩去维护正义吧。
你说猴子会抬头吗？
不会。
猴子不会抬头。
这一不行。
正义不是欲望。
或者说正义不够。
不够格。
做欲望。
对于我来说，对于我要求的故事来说。
那什么样的故事？
什么样的正义能让猴子抬头呢？
原始。
必须原始。
啊，同学们说哪有这这这这这种哪我跟你说很多的来。
你就往他旁块一蹲。
那棵树上有香蕉走。
他嘛跟你走。
对不对？他马上跟你走。
这叫什么？
这叫什么？这叫饥饿。
饥饿。
是欲望。
来一顿。
okK。
那边那个母猴，你看哪呢哪呢？
他又逮走了，他没逮到。
爱情。
对吧对爱情的追求。
追求爱情啊。
还蹲着呢啊。
哎嘿嘿哎哎别吃了别吃了。
我听说。
我这个上礼拜。
你想当猴王。
跟老大干了一仗。
你看你让他挠的。
对吧身上还有伤呢。
今天去今天。
去挠他。
我帮你。
猴子抬头了，看看。
觉得俩打一个可以走。
对不对？
又抬头了。
这是什么？
为什么？
复仇。
复仇还有什么？刚才这个么除了复仇，还有什么？
还有上位。
所以复仇和上位。
也是很原始的。
我跟你说，猴子不不那么简单的，有很多事可以让他抬头的。
找一个。
做咱的欲望。
正义。
动作。
我们说动作。
有什么要求？
及物。
动作必须是个及物动词。
抓捕。
是O的，抓不谁。
对吧它后面的接名词。
抓捕谁杀杀谁。
必须是个极物动词在这里。
问题我到世界了，好吧。
我们事件这里来讲问题。
就能不能的问题。
我们反复说啊，一个事件的核心问题就是能不能。
这个问题是什？
其实。
我们可以换一种理解方式啊。
他其实是个悬念。
他让你他支撑你，把这个戏看完，而且勾清你对这个戏的。
想象。
到底。
到底行不行？
所以。
这个悬念是不能断的。
你可以换。
但是不能断。
明白吧？可以换，也可以两个悬念重合。
就悬念不能断的。
然后尽量保证它的烈度越来越强。在故事中。
悬念不能断。
阻力。
阻力我们说了啊。
要很多。
要组合。
那大主力套小阻力，主主力，主主力跟着副主力。
组合。
他说是这么说呀，怎么实现呢？我们把阻力。
分3块，就你其他的阻力，你回头再写，你自己发挥想象，有三样阻力不要少。第一，环境带来的阻力。
第二，对手带来的阻力。
第三。
你自身。
你自己。
搞成的主力。而且一般来说啊。
这三个阻力是就是按这个顺序。
来的。
比如说我们说我们如果要写一个警察抓坏人的故事。
一般来说上来的阻力都是来自怀。
你看啊。
所以我说为什么这种片子不好审？
你警察的环境是什么？
其实是你的工作环境，你的警局，其他人都不想抓。
或者其他人都想保他，都拿了他的钱了。你这时候的这个阻力就就上来就是束手束脚，你这个环境阻力。
对一个警察来说。
那就是他的工作环境嘛。
我们说比如说警察局有内鬼。
或者是有坏人的保护伞。
或者是这整个警察局都让那个坏人给收买了，就你孤军奋战，这就是环境的阻力嘛。环境好吧，然后对手对手显而易见，那就是你要战胜的那些人，那就是你的对手，他们有多坏，你的任务就有多难。
来自对手的阻力。最后一种阻力。
是来自于自己的。
是来自于自自己的。你去看所有。
主力层次丰富的那种戏。
主角到最后。
需要战胜的其实是自己。
自己的利益取舍。
自己的。
叛念和正义的斗争。
是他最后自己的阻力。当然也有那种特别正义的。
有这种角色啊就倍正义，他自己没有动摇。
但也会做跟自我的主力。比如说他孩子让人绑架。
明白这意思吗？孩子在坏人手里。
那其实就是那你是到底是追求正义，还是保你孩子的命，这就是这还是跟自己的。
他一定程度上是概念上的跟自己的斗争。
因为你这主角设的太正了吧。
所以说阻力如果分成这三个设那。
这个问题主力这个问题又解决了。
对吧。
我们说结果。
怎么样实现精彩？怎么样实现在实战当中的精彩？
不就是他他达成了。
他想抓到坏人，最后抓着了吗？
对吧。
他想抓他的动作是抓坏人。
最后抓着了。
嗯。
这不就是结果吗？
这是最错误的地方。
大错特错。
结果我们要一个什么结果呢？
记住这个口诀。
记笔记啊，绕过动作。
实现欲网。
这是最好的结目。
就是你绕过你的动作。
实现你的欲望。
举个最简单的例子。
我是一个快要饿死的人。
我的欲望是什么？
我的欲望是。
求生。
你这跟猴子聊，欲望跟猴子聊，记得吧？我快饿死了，我当然想求生了，我不想死呀，对吧？那我的动作是什么呢？
那有个卖催饼的。
我想去偷饼。
就是我是一个非常饥饿的人，我的动作是去偷饼吃。
欲望是。
求生。
吃东西动作是偷饼。
那你这个故事的结局最好就是绕过动作实现欲望。就是你虽然没有偷到饼，或者是最后时刻。
被这人抓着了，发现你偷饼，你没有偷到饼，或者你自己放弃了，没有偷到饼。但是你实现了欲望。
卖饼的人给了一张饼。
别偷了，以后饿了，跟我说。
我们要这种结局，懂吗？
绕过动作，实现欲望。
你先把这个记下来以后，你会经常用到的绕过动作实现欲望。